Bill O'Reilly is taking a vacation in
the midst of the sexual harassment
controversy at least five women have
settled with Fox News for the total
amount of 13 million dollars Bill
O'Reilly has lost 60 advertisers from
the show and as a result he is now
taking a vacation that he claims is a
part of a plan vacation he takes every
year the timing is mighty convenient Pat
what do you think yeah very interesting
timing and recently one of his shows was
cut short by another 15 minutes
completely unexpectedly an unplanned
right because well once you have once
you plan for about 15 minutes worth of
appetizers and then 14 minutes north of
advertisers say we no longer want to do
business with you it makes sense that
you're going to have a programmatic
problem that's when they had Shepard
Smith I remember breaking in with
breaking news that wasn't really
breaking news right and you know this is
part of the culture over at Fox News we
know that Roger Ailes their longtime CEO
went down under similar things and
Donald Trump came to Bill O'Reilly
defense here which is probably the last
person that you want here's the irony of
this so it amidst the sexual harassment
controversy taking a vacation losing
advertisers Donald Trump has a mean I
don't let from a bill o'reilly has a new
book entitled old school which is a bill
to be according to new york times a
defense of traditional values and this
is in a report by new york times it
includes advice on how men should treat
women respectfully and not just as sex
objects the book is scheduled to be a
number one New York Times bestseller in
non fix in the non fiction category I
mean you can't just oppose this with any
greater irony a man who is having to
take a vacation because of sexual
harassment lawsuits having a number one
seller on how to treat women with
respect and not as sexual objects it's
pretty creative damage control but it
doesn't seem to make sense I honestly
think that the show could survive this
though because even though he's losing
advertisers like mercedes-benz and you
know the big names out there I think
that advertisers who also put their
commercials up on Breitbart and The
Drudge Report
these other types of shows would be
willing to put it on fox news as well
and O'Reilly show is still the top rated
cable news show and has actually gone up
in rating since the scandal broke but
ironically not ironically so to respond
to what you're saying it's possible what
you're saying is very possible but can
they make up the financial shortfall
right you're talking about hundreds of
millions of dollars of revenue that's
being lost if these advertisers stay
away permanently and I don't know if any
combination of groups can make up
mercedes-benz and 60-59 other companies
they certainly will make it up entirely
but if the other advertisers are willing
to pay maybe eighty percent or ninety
percent and going to be worth it for
them to keep bill o'reilly on well
according to some reports this time a
way for Bill O'Reilly may be his final
exit from Fox News a couple of insiders
of Fox News who of course reported under
with anonymity say that this is a
vacation for him to exit but Bill
O'Reilly disagrees he says that he'll be
back on April 24th we'll see who wins
out which faction of Fox News wins out